frédéric duval bonjour bonjour aux
auditrices et auditeurs de martinique
première alors vous avez 69 ans vous
êtes retraité de l'éducation nationale
vous êtes maire de la trinité depuis
et vous allez mener la liste dynamique
trinitéenne c'est bien ça tout à fait
qu'est ce qui motive encore votre
candidature
mais voilà j'ai été candidat en 2014 la
population de notre unité m'a élu en
tant que mère avec un programme
électoral que j'ai menées depuis et 2014
et nous arrivons au bout de ce programme
qui est devenu programme de gestion en
2001 jusqu'en 2020 et nous avons
commencé beaucoup d'opérations à la
trinité qui ne sont pas terminées mais
aussi on était venu avec un projet
global
un projet sur plusieurs années donc nous
estimons les membres de dynamique
trinitéenne qu'il faut continuer
continuer à investir la trinité à
développer la trinité c'est cette raison
que je suis candidat lors de votre
présentation de candidature vous avez
réalisé un véritable déploiement de
force avec la présence pas moins de six
mères et d'une députée cite un moyen de
dire que vous étiez que vous êtes bien
vivant que vous n'êtes pas mort et que
vous n'êtes pas seuls eh bien je ne sais
pas pourquoi on la lit consumant reçu
seul un seul cas je n'ai jamais été
j'ai toujours été dans ma population
mais aussi aux six membres la communauté
d'agglomération de cap nord et vous avez
bien dû remarquer que tous les maires de
cap nau étaient présents parce que je me
revendique d'un cap nau aussi alors que
se passe-t-il duval avec louis joseph
manscour il dit que vous avez humilié et
c'est pour cela qu'ils soutiennent
annick charles heck
alors je vous dirais que je suis dans
une campagne électorale pour défendre un
bilan et pour proposer à la population
des projets pour la mandature de 2020
2026 et que tout le reste pour moi n'est
qu'artifice ça ne se regardent pas les
trinitéens les trinitaires n'ont pas
besoin de savoir je n'ai pas un problème
particulier je n'ai aucun problème donc
ma campagne électorale va se dérouler à
défaut de mon bilan et a donné mes
projets pour 2020 2026
la trinité est un bastion socialiste
depuis 1945 avec auguste région puis
casimir grande comprendre leader puis
lui joseph manscour vous est ce que vous
êtes toujours socialiste
je suis de coeur socialiste mais j'ai
fondé un mouvement qui s'appelle
dynamique interne en juin 2018 donc et
un c'est un mouvement qui regroupe les
trinités inscrits et haine qui veulent
travailler pour la trinité qui sont
d'obédience de gauche donc je me
revendique de coeur socialiste est ce
que vous comprenez le parti socialiste
quand il dit qu'il a été trahi qui non
je vous dis que pour l'instant fenech
buval droite dans une campagne
électorale et qui n'a pas à faire état
des états d'âme des uns et des autres
alors quels seront les grands axes de
votre campagne vous allez poursuivre
quels seront les contrats fait donc nous
avons au cours de cette mandature
développer la trinité est mis en place
les opérations pour lesquelles nous
étions élus notamment avec la
construction d'une école parasismiques à
beauséjour la construction d'un
boulodrome à beauséjour parce que vous
savez que la trinité c'est un bastion où
on pratique la pétanque et qu'il était
normal de donner aux boulistes un
terrain digne de ce nom et c'est un
terrain de pétanque qui sera à dimension
régionale et internationale mais aussi
nous avons mis en place une politique
sportive pour développer les sports
nautiques et c'est ainsi que sur le
quartier autre bord nous avons créé une
somme en train de crier mini base
nautique qui va permettre aux élèves du
primaire aux collégiens aux lycéens aux
adhérents des associations de vous
pouvez venir pratiquer la voile à la
trinité certains de vos adversaires
disent que le bourg de trinité se meurt
on y arrive on n'arrive pas à s'y garer
et que qu'on n'arrive plus à dire en
bulles et comme alors si on n'arrive pas
à se garer ça veut dire qu'il ya des
véhicules qui y sont et si lé véhicule
c'est qu'il ya des chalands qui viennent
la trinité faut faire locaux sont bien
disons que ce qu'il avait dit le brut
isolés y aura pas eu une voiture d arrêt
une fois en face de vous dire que la
trinité n'a jamais été aussi active que
depuis qu'on a su mer et je ne dis pas
que de la pas été avant mais nous avons
continué à mettre en place une
attractivité sur la trinité et en plus
beaucoup de commerçants viennent
s'installer sur la trinité
la cnds est l'une des villes les plus
festives les plus animés de la
martinique il n'y a pas un samedi un
week-end ou pendant les vacances petites
et grandes vacances où il n'ya pas
d'animation à trinité à l'intention des
commerçants à l'état sion des
associations à l'intention du social à
l'intention des jeunes donc manque un
véritable hôtel à il manque un véritable
hôtel la trinité fournit un hôtel quand
vous dites il manque un véritable hôtel
je sais pas de quoi vous voulez parler
non parce que là maintenant a pas
matière d'hôtellerie
il faut comprendre que la martinique n'a
plus la possibilité d'avoir des hôtels
de grand luxe des hôtels cinq étoiles
qu'il faut qu'on se mettre à la page du
jour pour recevoir tous les touristes
qui viennent à montigny la salinité bien
fourni en hôtel mais nous avons aussi
des difficultés sur la trinité par
rapport à cet hôtel donc voulu aussi que
si je suis candidat c'est parce que
l'ige un programme qui sera mis en place
pour 2020 2026 et nous avons la
possibilité
nous sommes en train de construire ce
programme
donc j'invite les uns et les autres à
venir nos union pour entendre ce que
nous avons fait frédéric duval je vous
remercie
je vous en prie et merci beaucoup
[Musique]